[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur la chaîne
parlementaire de l'assemblée nationale
téléphone a sonné dans ma voiture et
c'était laurent fabius et il m'appelait
mme lise est est ce que ça te dirait
d'être président de la chaîne
parlementaire qu'on va créer et je me
suis dit oh là là le palais bourbon
j'y allais comme journaliste et la vie
démocratique mois la république il y a
que ça qui m'intéresse la citoyenneté la
lundi dernier la chaîne parlementaire
faisait ses premiers pas trois mois à
peine après la promulgation de la loi
prévoyant sa création les sénateurs
voulaient leur chaîne a&e et les députés
voulaient leur chaîne à e
donc on a coupé la pomme en deux une
moitié de pommes pour le sénat et
l'autre moitié pour l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
je voulais que la chaîne parlementaire
ne s'occupe que du parlement et donc je
voulais qu'on soit dans le parlement
nous sommes sous la salle des quatre
colonnes
les députés sont au dessus un laitage il
descend d'un étage ils sont là donc nous
aurons j'allais dire le show le très
chaud et même le brûlant j'ai dit à la
première équipe notre terrain de jeu
si je peux dire notre travail c'est le
parlement on n'essaie pas de devenir une
télévision comme les autres on est une
telle vision politique il a fallu des
années je rends grâce à ce et les
députés et les journalistes successeur
qui ont obtenu le droit d'aller voir des
députés qui travaillent en commission là
quand je vois lcp que je regarde que je
regarde parce que bien de voir l'enfant
grandit l'enfant il est né
d'un couple intelligent je dis pas que
laurent fabius et pensait avec des
moeurs différente des moeurs majoritaire
mais il se trouve que le couple a fait
un bébé
elkabbach a été nourrissent d'une moitié
et moi j'ai été un temps nourrissent de
l'autre de l'autre moitié par avec
clément vous êtes dans la cité eh bien
oui la chaîne la chaîne a 20 ans et sait
et c'est formidable